maintenant
le président de la République
turcum va apprendre la parole je le prie
de bien vouloir
venir au micro
Monsieur le Secrétaire général
chers membres des délégations je vous
salue avec mes sentiments les plus
cordiaux et avec respect
nous sommes à Istanbul lieu de rencontre
des civilisations et des continents
soyez tous les bienvenus en date du 29
mars
nous avions eu une réunion très
importante suite à celle-ci nous sommes
à nouveau ensemble réunis ici
et nous accueillons nous vous
accueillons vous nos chers amis à
l'occasion d'une journée historique à
nouveau à Istanbul j'en suis
particulièrement ravi
cette crise globale alimentaire
tracassé le monde depuis très longtemps
et je nous vivons la fierté de pouvoir
avoir contribué à résoudre cette
situation de jusqu'à l'Afrique au
Moyen-Orient dans le monde entier des
milliards d'êtres humains pouvaient être
confrontés à une grave crise élémentaire
et tous ensemble nous allons pouvoir y
apporter une réponse en matière de
produits alimentaires il est évidemment
impératif de pouvoir assurer la sécurité
alimentaire dans dans le monde entier il
y a en plus la crise du au réchauffement
climatique qui va probablement avoir une
influence sur la montée des prix de
cette façon nous pourrons également y
contribuer et réduire ces prix là cette
inflation sur les denrées alimentaires
nous pourrons à y contribuer grâce à
l'accord qui est signé aujourd'hui
évidemment nous ne sommes pas parvenus à
cet accord du jour au lendemain
nous avons eu des entretiens intenses
avec les responsables des Nations Unies
notamment
avec nos homologues russes et ukrainien
également nous étions en permanence en
contact avec eux et les chacun de ces
deux pays avaient des inquiétudes
avaient des attentes nous avons eu un
processus de consultation très intense
pour parvenir à résoudre des points de
blocage
mes ministres en charge des affaires
étrangères et de la défense ils ont
contribué grandement le secrétaire
général des Nations Unies et son équipe
ils ont également contribué ça a eu
énormément d'importance pour arriver à
un accord
en conséquence de tout cela
messieurs Poutine et zenanski ont
contribue également la signature de cet
accord je tenais à les remercier tout
particulièrement grâce au trafic
maritime qui pourra commencer dans les
jours à venir sur la mer Noire il y aura
une nouvelle voie qui permettra au monde
de respirer grâce à ce trafic qui va
voir le jour emmerdoise c'est
navire pourront circuler en toute
sécurité et un accord a été compliqué a
été conclu sur toutes les parties de ce
de ce transport le contrôle sera
effectué à Istanbul grâce à un centre
commun de coordination dans le centre
sera Istanbul
le plan devra évidemment être appliqué
avec sévérité et de ce point de vue là
la communauté internationale devrait
également y contribuer jouer un rôle
éminent chers amis il y a environ quatre
mois de cela
nous étions à nouveau à Istanbul et sous
nos hospites il y a eu des entretiens
qui ont eu lieu entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine et nous avions des espoirs
pour que la guerre puisse cesser
incessamment sous peu malheureusement
les évolutions qui ont suivi après cette
réunion dédiée à 4 mois ont en venimé le
conflit depuis le début nous avons
toujours dit qu'il n'y aurait aucun
vainqueur à ce conflit que tout pas
simplement les parties engagées le monde
entier avait perdre de cette guerre
environ depuis 5 mois ce conflit continu
sans arrêt sans discontinuer
malheureusement les effets globaux nous
ont montré que nous avions raison de
prédire les effets négatifs de cette de
cette tant que les armes ne se te rend
pas ne se déront pas évidemment les
pertes humaines augmenteront également
cette guerre ne concerne pas simplement
les parties engagées ne concerne pas
simplement les pays engagés cette guerre
a une influence négative sur le monde
entier sur les populations du monde
entier mais ce n'est pas inscrit dans le
destin nous pouvons empêcher que cela
continue cette guerre entraîne des
victimes humaines des victimes
innocentes et nous voulons que cette
guerre puisse prendre fin le plus
rapidement possible il n'y aura aucun
perdant si nous arrivons à une paix
juste aujourd'hui avec la Russie avec
l'Ukraine nous avons engagé une un pas
important et je pense que cela sera
peut-être du moins j'en ai l'espoir que
cela pourra ouvrir la voie à un nouvel
avenir
les évolutions sur le terrain peu
importe dans quel sens elle continue la
guerre quoi qu'il en soit devra se
terminer à la table des négociations
cette ambiance pacifique que nous avons
créé aujourd'hui j'espère qu'elle pourra
servir à d'autres pas qui seront fait en
faveur de la paix c'est la
responsabilité que nous avons c'est la
responsabilité que nous avons qui
découle de notre conception de la
civilisation tout d'abord nous
continuerons jusqu'à ce que la paix
règne dans cette région nous ferons tout
en tant que pays voisins à assurer cela
je souhaite que Dieu nous aide dans ce
sens et en terminant mes propos en
terminant mes propos je vous remercie
tous réellement tous pour tous les
efforts que vous avez consentis de faire
et l'accord qui va être signé
aujourd'hui sera
porteur de très bonnes choses pour toute
la région pour
pour tous les peuples et je remercie
tous ceux en mon nom je remercie en mon
nom au nom de mon assiant tous ceux qui
ont contribué à la réalisation de cet
accord une fois de plus je vous salue
tous avec respect
nous remercions de notre président de la
République pour les propos qu'il vient
de tenir